at first glance sleeping dogs might seem
like an overly familiar video game as an
undercover cop embedded in an organized
crime syndicate you wander around a city
steal cars complete missions if this all
sounds a little too grand theft auto
think again what sets sleeping dogs
apart is that it's set in the city of
Hong Kong it has martial arts brawling
that really feels more like something
out of Arkham Asylum we talked to square
enix about how sleeping dogs could be
this e3's sleeper hit with sydney dogs
really tried to focus on you know the
core mechanics a lot of open world games
really sort of forsaken the hand-to-hand
combat driving the shooting and they've
done that to sort of at the expense
against of the ability to sandbox game I
do whatever you want we said well I
think we can do both you can still have
that sandbox experience Jennifer mission
the mission do whatever you want to
explore the world but really have great
hand to hand combat and make a great
racing experience so bring that all
together and making a really fun
playable experience that's also open
world has a great compelling story
you're set in Hong Kong and you're an
undercover cop valuation he grew up in
Hong Kong was in you know with a bit of
a rough crowd his parents took him to
the states to kind of get away from it
all and later on he's asked to join this
past course to reuse contacts and
connections he from his childhood to try
and infiltrate the Triads and take them
down on sleeping dogs who spent a lot of
time on our combat right from the
beginning we knew that was probably you
know one of our most core features we
take a lot of influences from Hong Kong
cinema where the hero surrounded by 2030
enemies and they've got to use their
within their environment and their
martial arts skills to get himself out
of the situation and incapacitate all
the other thugs around them and so we've
built it a system that we feel is really
fluid it's very intuitive easy to pick
up and play but there's also a lot of
depth so at united front games we've got
a long pedigree experience of working on
racing titles we kind of took all these
different driving game experiences and
brought it to sleeping dogs trying to
create a somewhat realistic experience
but erring on the side of fun and our
cave and we thought was important if
you're going it's a big city you're
driving all around Hong Kong Island but
if you're going from point A to point B
you want that to be an enjoyable
experience